so uh it's kind of a crazy story uh
there's a YouTuber named Hunter Avalon
we've had him on the show before I think
a couple years ago and I had no idea
that he lived or uh yeah I guess he
lived like like a couple doors down from
our building in Martinsburg West
Virginia where we have people currently
doing work and uh I'm I'm I'm just
finding I just started finding the story
out like an hour ago not even some guy
showed up he so he's dating someone that
guy's uh that woman's exoy boyfriend
came with a shotgun fired through the
door striking the woman trying to kill
Hunter avalone at least it appears
according to text messages that were
released and uh I don't know just it's
just crazy a little shook up I had to
you know call family
because it's just I don't know it's a
crazy story